while the words gift in Dark Souls don't
seem to belong in the same sentence
both Dark Souls 1 and to give you the
choice to choose a starting item as you
customize your character however in
classic Souls II and style some of these
items descriptions are a bit vague so
let's sort out which gift you should
choose when beginning your journey your
first choice is nothing if you can't
sort that one out on your own Dark Souls
may not be for you the life ring on the
other hand is a similar item to the tiny
beings ring in Dark Souls 1 it increases
your health by a small percentage and
isn't a bad choice for the early game
though there may be better the human
effigy is comparable to a humanity from
the first Dark Souls but even more
essential as Dark Souls to Doc's your
total health following each and every
death using the item will remove this
debuff and restore your humanity or you
could also just murder these innocent
old ladies for some if that's how you
roll the healing wares option gives you
a gift package of healing items
including an additional 10 life gems 3
radiant life gems and an old radiant
life gym all of which will regenerate
your health over time in addition to 5
poisoned mosses which ironically cure
poison the homeward bone option is a bit
short-sighted seeing is these are a more
common item in the souls universe but
they're still useful for escaping a
risky scenario with your souls intact
next is a seed of a tree of giants this
mysterious item will allow the monsters
in the area to attack invaders allowing
you to lure other players into traps and
use the environment to your advantage in
PvP bouts this adds a new layer of
complexity to competitive play in Dark
Souls and is a clever addition the
bonfire aesthetic is an item that will
strengthen all enemies near the bonfire
where it's used well this may sound
masochistic using this item will cause
enemies to drop better items that would
only drop at higher difficulty levels
and using the item after defeating a
boss on your first playthrough will
revive the boss at new game+ difficulty
finally the petrified something does
nothing on its own but it can be traded
to silky The Crow for a random item the
drop very is seemingly by class as it
yielded a white ring for my swordsman
but a titanite slab as a knight that
does it for our Dark Souls 2 gift
starter guide so choose wisely and
praise the Sun
you